Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Dr. Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
With the increased popularity of online meetings,
telepresence applications are on the rise
where we can talk to each other from afar.
Today, let’s see how these powerful, new
neural network-based learning methods can
be applied to them.
It turns out, they can help us do everyone’s
favorite, which is, showing up to a meeting,
and changing our background to pretend we
are somewhere else.
Now that is a deceptively difficult problem.
Here, the background has been changed, that
is the easier problem, but, look!
The lighting of the new environment hasn’t
been applied to the subject.
And now, hold on to your papers, and check
this out.
This is the result of the new technique after
it recreates the image as if she was really
there.
I particularly like the fact that the result
includes high-quality specular highlights
too, or in other words, the environment reflecting
off of our skin.
However, of course, this is not the first
method attempting this.
So let’s see how it performs compared to
the competition!
These techniques are from one and two years
ago, and…they don’t perform so well.
Not only did they lose a lot of detail all
across the image, but, the specular highlights
are gone.
As a result, the image feels more like a video
game character than a real person.
Luckily, the authors also have access to the
reference information to make our job of comparing
the results easier.
Roughly speaking, the more the outputs look
like this, the better.
So now, hold on to your papers, and let’s
see how the new method performed.
Oh yes!
Now we’re talking!
Now, of course, not even this is perfect.
Clearly, the specularity of clothing was determined
incorrectly, and the matting around the thinner
parts of the hair could be better, which is
notoriously difficult to get right.
But, this is such a huge step forward in just
one paper.
And we are not nearly done - there are two
more things that I found to be remarkable
about this work.
One, is that the whole method was trained
on still images, yet, it still works on video
too!
And we don’t have any apparent temporal
coherence issues, or in other words, no flickering
arises from the fact that it processes the
video as not a video, but a series of separate
images.
Very cool.
Two, if we are in a meeting with someone and
we like their background, we can simply borrow
it.
Look.
This technique can take their image, get the
background out, estimate its lighting, and
give the whole package to us too.
I think this will be a game changer.
People may start to become more selective
with these backgrounds, not just because of
how the background looks, but, because how
it makes them look.
Remember, lighting off of a well chosen background
makes a great deal of a difference in our
appearance in the real world, and now, with
this method in virtual worlds too.
And this will likely happen not decades from
now, but in the near future.
So this new method is clearly capable of some
serious magic.
But how?
What is going on under the hood to achieve
this?
This method performs two important steps to
accomplish this, step number one is matting.
This means separating the foreground from
the background, and then, if done well, we
can now easily cut out the background and
also have the subject on a separate layer
and proceed to step number two.
Which is, relighting.
In this step, the goal is to estimate the
illumination of the new scene and recolor
the subject as if she were really there.
This new technique performs both, but most
of the contributions lie in this step.
To be able to accomplish this, we have to
be able to estimate the material properties
of the subject.
The technique has to know one, where the diffuse
parts are, these are the parts that don’t
change too much as the lighting changes, and
two, where the specular parts are, in other
words, shiny regions that reflect back the
environment more clearly.
Putting it all together, we get really high-quality
relighting for ourselves, and given that this
was developed by Google, I expect that this
will supercharge our meetings quite soon.
And just imagine what we will have two more
papers down the line.
My goodness, what a time
to be alive!
Thanks
for watching and for your generous support,
and I'll see you next time!